- A mistrial is declared
in the California case
against Michael Avenatti.
In this particular case,
Michael Avenatti was cross-examining
a member of the Treasury Department
and questioning why the government
didn't turn over specific accounting data
to him and his defense team,
although those are sort of
one in the same at this point.
Avenatti claimed that this
evidence was exculpatory
and integral to his defense
and that it was wrong for the government
to not turn it over
before the trial happened.
The government said that
this data was effectively
not important whatsoever
and was not exculpatory
but the judge agreed with Michael Avenatti
and declared a mistrial.
That does not mean that
Michael Avenatti is going free.
It just means that the government
will have to retry Michael Avenatti.
A mistrial doesn't mean that
people go off scot-free.
It just means that this trial
is declared null and void
and the government has
to do it all over again.
The judge didn't think
that the government had
committed any wrongdoing,
but they should have turned this data
over to Michael Avenatti.
It was prejudicial.
So we're gonna have to do
this whole thing over again,
so I will see them in court.